*ripping sound*
*fun, upbeat pop music*
No. I refuse.
Well it tastes like sherbert.
It kind of looks like a smoothie right now.
It is. It's like generic berry.
Yeah. I don't like it.
It's like if you were to dip fruit into chocolate with no nutritional value.
Like if I'm going to do this, I'm going to eat the fruit and not gain 10 pounds.
*fun, upbeat pop music*
Ooo! I'm so excited!
There's some high expectations.
Mmm! These are good.
This is cookie dough flavored cream
A really terrible, fake cookie dough taste.
Everything I dreamed of.
That doesn't taste anything like cookie dough.
I'm underwhelmed.
*fun, upbeat pop music*
Banana split!
The banana is overwhelming.
Ahhh!
Is it bad?
There are a lot of flavors happening in my mouth right now.
This is chaos.
I like it.
*intense shade being thrown*
No, it's the fake strawberry that's really awful.
Dial it down, Oreo.
*fun, upbeat pop music*
Ooo!
The only thing that watermelon should be mixed with is vodka.
This looks like play dough.
This is adorable.
It tastes like watermelon and jolly rancher
Wait! It does taste like watermelon.
Not bad.
Yeah.
This is good.
I know!
*fun, upbeat pop music*
That tastes just like Minute Maid limeade.
Mmm-hmm.
You know this is gross.
Ooo! The end of this is so sugary and limey.
It assaults you.
This is like the food equivalent of a limearita.
It tastes like a mojito.
Yeah. Like a sh*t mojito.
Oh God.
*fun, upbeat pop music*
It smells like you threw up after eating fruit punch.
It kind of smells like Kool-Aid.
Oh I don't like that.
*disgusted sound*
It tastes like a pixie stick.
It's like somebody dipped a packet of pre-made drink into the Oreo cream.
The sugar overload is like *exploding sound*.
I mean it is really accurate. It's crazy.
*fun, upbeat pop music*
Now this I'm excited for.
I feel like I just walked into Starbucks.
It tastes like pumpkin pie. It's great.
Tastes like fall.
It's kind of like ginger snappy.
It's a good mix of flavors.
Having the cookie there is like the crust to the pumpkin pie.
This one's pretty good.
I would have this after Thanksgiving for sure.
Can I cookie monster these Oreos?
No!
Arh-garh-gah! Ha-ha!
Ned! *chuckling*